so first of all a brief introduction on
screen suffice who we are and what we do
sort of in the county so you can see the
three things that we do there are
locations talent crew and permitting
and what that is is we are a film office
which was set up in 2016 and all of the
councils in suffolk came together and
decided there was an opportunity with
the film industry to further the film
industry um and sort of benefit from all
the the great things that come from
filming suffolk and you can see i'm
going to be showing you some pictures of
some of the productions that we've had
in suffolk um and i'll also show you a
short show reel that we've just put
together that gives you an idea of some
of the things that we've that have been
shot in the county so this is uh
yesterday with danny boyle and richard
curtis film that was shot in and around
suffolk a couple of years ago and this
is down at shingle street
um and this was for actually the shop
that this was being filmed is in the
showroom you'll see it's one long shot
sweeping along but you can see the
amount of people that are involved
in getting a very simple shot the crews
are very very big and this production
was about 150
and then more importantly um locally for
you guys this was shot in kersey
um and this is a production for
brick box which is going to be out
coming out next year which is an anthony
horowitz series called magpie murders
and we did lots of things like closing
the roads
um and making sure that people were safe
and there's a crew this was quite a
small crew of about 50 people
and it's one of the things that screen
suffolk does is we manage any incoming
production and all of the locations that
are available in suffolk
so other things that you've seen in that
shots there we've had the dig we've got
yesterday uh did anybody spot berry sent
edmonds
yeah so you've got that's for the
personal history of david copperfield
and lots of examples of the things there
was a film called the institute by a
theater company called gecko that was
shot at bentwaters
which is a big old military base uh
that's kind of not too far away from
here and that just shows some of the
things that have happened in suffolk
since screen suffolk started
now one of the things that we do at
screen suffolk is we manage locations
so if you're a production you want to
come and shoot on the beach in suffolk
or you want to shoot in very saint
edmonds or
lavender um then you would come to us
and because we work on behalf of all of
the councils we authorize and arrange
for that filming to happen we're really
the bridge between
um the production company and the
councils um the film industry is our
business we know how it all works and we
sort of help find
locations but we also look for things
like unit bases which is where the
production stays with all the vehicles
and trucks and catering
and you can see here that we've got
hundreds of locations dotted around
suffolk
and as well as having all the council
locations we also look after private
locations
so if you've got a house or an air base
or a field we can represent people and
and manage filming on on their behalf
and here's an example of you can see all
the sort of different things that we
have um here's just sort of the front
page of the 500 locations that we have
and you can see we've got like georgia
style houses we've got big we've got the
mix which is based near here um we've
got lots of sort of visitor centers
cottages we've got lots of sort of um
we've got one up here menden mill
gardens which is um a big old water
wheel um and so it's a full range of
things that we can offer out to
productions
and this is this was filming in very
saint edwards uh for the personal
history of david copperfield the
gentleman in the blue shirt and the cap
in the middle is armando anuchi who's a
director of the project um and the shot
that you're seeing that's being taken
here you saw on the show reel which is
the big sweeping shot of very saint
edmunds
so we look after all the kind of filming
um within suffolk
and this was actually a production um
in lavanam which was about probably
three or four weeks ago
and for a new film uh coming out called
cold harbor lane that's a netflix
co-production
now one of the things that we do do as
well as looking after locations we've
got crewing on there as well so we have
two databases that we run for crew
the first database is for people that
are actively working in the industry and
you go to our website and register for
the role
and if any of you are out there working
now then i'd suggest you go along to our
website and register because any
opportunities that come in
we'll look up your name on the database
the skill set that you have
and then we can put your name forward if
they're looking for any crew
for the production
but we also have
a database which is for training and
career opportunities which are pr is
probably more relevant to you guys here
today
and what that is is that's people that
are looking for their first break in the
industry looking to be perhaps a a
location marshal or a runner
and whenever anybody production comes
into the county we always ask the
production do you need any runners do
you need any entry-level positions um
and we take names off that database so
if you go to our website which is
screensuffer.com
and follow the links through for career
and training opportunities uh we'll then
have your details if if any
opportunities are suitable arise
um and these are all the location
marshals that were all entry level
people um working on yesterday the danny
boyle and richard curtis film from a few
years ago
so that's a very quick talk about screen
suffer
you